the ice outside tomorrow sports director
chris matthews joining us live from
lake tahoe hey chris
how you doing guys i'll tell you what a
great day up here at lake tahoe getting
ready for the big weekend the nhl
outdoor weekend four teams are up here
and one of those teams
the vegas golden knights are going to
take on the avalanche and an outdoor
rink built right next to lake tahoe
joining me now is the owner of the uh
the franchise mr bill foley and bill
this setting up here is phenomenal and
to be one of these four teams that's
pretty special
it's uh it's really special we're
privileged to be here
i'm really looking forward to going to
the game unfortunately we don't have
enough fans at this game just a
few of the owner's reps and so on but
it's going to be great takes me back to
my time in ottawa canada
when when i started playing hockey and
our parents would go out and they'd
sweep off the ice on pond on a pond or
sweep off the snow off a pond
and you play pond hockey and that's
that's why these guys that are
playing tomorrow they love it you know
that's that's how they started
well and they were out there on the ice
for their very first practice today kind
of getting a feel for it they were
taking selfies because the setting is
gorgeous
it is unbelievable i mean so we're
sitting we get to not only watch the
games we get to see the lake
it's really going to be pretty and i'm
i'm really looking forward to it
the guys are excited this is this is
normally you know the families come up
to and
it's really kind of a real fun time
almost like a mini super bowl
but unfortunately the families can't be
here for this one so it's the biggest
golden knights and the avalanche
tomorrow but i got to ask you looking
down the road a little bit coming up in
march
i know a lot of people in las vegas want
to know can we get back inside the
fortress
and watch some golden knights games well
i hope we can
the governor's has now said 20 occupancy
beginning march first unfortunately
clark county
health commissioner or department said
oh no only 15 percent and that includes
suites so
we would we were hoping we were going to
have about 35 or 3 700 people
on for the minnesota games on the first
and third of march and looks like it's
less than that so
i don't know i don't know what it takes
just to let's let's get back to let's
have a life you know let's get back to
normal
and as you always say let's have some
fun let's have some fun let's have some
fun let's go see
let's go watch a hockey game and get
excited
that's what we're all about we're up
here in tahoe we're all excited here's
one of our favorite guys mr bill foley
appreciate you joining us live here
we'll have much more for you tonight at
six and tonight at 11 o'clock
as the vegas golden knights get ready to
take on the avalanche absolutely
gorgeous setting
reporting from south tahoe chris
matthews 8 sports now
can't wait to see it tomorrow